that I think that's why I could never
fight in MMA I never wanted to be in
that close proximity with another man's
toes you can mm-hmm that's why fighting
at a pool is weird mm-hmm like you you
cuz you know when you get to this to the
peacocking phase and you get to the nose
to nose if if the feet touch ya you
could feel their it's a little little
digits yeah it's a little you know I
mean he accidentally toe on toe oh yes
sorry sorry cross big toes bye oh [ __ ]
sorry that was nice though did we just
toasted these guys I used to work with
our brothers up before they call that
the Venice handshake there's these two
art directors they always wore sandals
they were complete psychopath I love him
to death
shout out my god Bob he's like born and
raised Venice dude hilarious guy him and
this dude James they they just straight
toe scissor
it took a picture and they would send it
as an email signature the Venice
handshake so gross it's so funny it's so
I remember my boy Ken's I'd say he told
me about it he's like you ever seen the
Venice handshake I first started working
there I said the what and Bob and James
just started laughing their asses off
there they show him show kids is like I
can't believe I got this in my phone
dude that Scrolls all the way back in
his photos and he just like covers his
eyes and turns the phone to me I'm like
yeah you guys what and they just think
oh why does that that why does that feel
so much more intimate than a handshake I
don't know it's just
it should never it's never how weird you
feel when you even touch feet with
someone else
it's just like you [ __ ] oh yeah oh my
god the first thing you do is apologize
yeah because you're like oh my god I
think I'm not trying not trying to
trying like what what could you be
trying like but yeah it does feel that
way Toronto Oh yo yo sorry this meant to
guys
rapping at the pool Tonto mm-hmm that
would set it off I think he's just
[ __ ] no no you just do it as a sign of
alpha yeah what's up what's up oh oh
[ __ ] just locked all her toes were like
this it's like the handshake or you
[ __ ] interlock the what's up brah oh
oh oh yo Bryson you got to swing on him
he's got my foot dawg you put me in a
Chinese foot trap oh [ __ ] Dawg what's up
bro what's up balanced and perfect
unlike the other ones yeah you're both
sitting down his boys are holding him by
his cheeks and he's got both your feet
locked what's up brah what's up what you
finna do now huh what you gonna do
nothing we are locked right now rope
holding ass yeah bro what you finna do
huh
what you gonna do what you gotta do huh
me I dare you I [ __ ] dare you swam I
swam my partner right here watch what
happened to you
doesn't even get close cuz they're
locked like this exactly exactly exactly
exactly
disengage that's what I thought dude
starts crying yeah yeah and if you if
you if you want it too I'll lock any one
of you all of you can get it any day
this week ma'am then he goes like this
wait ilysm for the whole pool thing
what say yeah yeah go forget it that's
disgusting toes just like it's one
individually moving forget it he's
rolling a quarter on his toes like a
magician like to see
and don't you forget I don't wanna
[ __ ] and don't you forget it
points them like a synchronized swimmer
it's in the pool [ __ ] it's a party
the picture there's a party's to kick
back tell it dudes in there I'm
picturing this it's like it's a lot you
know the vibe is kind of cool but it's
tense right just not enough girls in
there to make it make it cool yeah and a
dude walks in and somebody's like lost
this [ __ ] and he's like yo David
come over here hold my sock holds up his
single foot starts walking around the
party but they start carrying him around
the party ever was like oh [ __ ] so when
I got here it seemed like somebody had a
problem so I just want to let everybody
know uh
you [ __ ] right here is this
hookah hose take this [ __ ] back anybody
could get it picks up the beer pong ball
hits the last Cup
damn that was tight alright so if you
anyone got it want to get it again with
me I'll be in the kitchen you you you
you could get it you you could get Bob
and dudes on their nose with his toe you
you could get it you
[Laughter]
you could get it Brad make a stop Brad
[ __ ] that sounds like this
terrorizing the party with your with
your toes it is so funny somebody act
out okay that's gonna be my new threat
you keep talking man I'm coming over
there and put my toes put my toes in
your mouth you know say something else
mm-hmm what what do you say in your
mouth that's what I do in the UFC I get
a dude I like try to take his back and
put his foot I guess so flexible walking
at my toes up into his mouth and just
guy with the toe in his mouth just
tapping from the toe being on his lips
and the ref is like nah fam that's you
can't tap for that that's not a legal
that has got to be like a finishing move
knocks himself out holy [ __ ]
you know speaking of weird ass fighting
technique I forget this dude's name
doesn't even it doesn't even deserve to
be remembered but he had a weird ass
fight as a UFC card this weekend and
this dude I was impressed it the fight
felt like a nine-year-old fighting a
seven-year-old mm-hmm we're not a nine
year old is older and it knows a little
more but he doesn't have necessarily a
huge physical advantage so I just felt
like two dudes trying to figure out how
to beat each other up and this guy his
his thing was kicks so he would throw
these like weird like you throw two
kicks in a row and they were like full
like 360 like high kicks and [ __ ] he
look like he was dancing around the ring
but and be able to do it back up and
like get out the way and then this dude
would just like stand there
you kind of walk forward and stand again
and then if the other guy got too close
he would run away and reposition himself
and throw more kicks in the air and then
he might like slap him on the titty like
he was like just making tiring himself
out no it was it was just tiring to
watch but like he had all the energy in
the world but he like was it was like
non fighting I was like okay I've never
believed it possible to script a fight
in the UFC until now this dude had it
down he throw kicks and he looked like
real big and kind of like flashy and
then he'd be like oh one point cuz he
just just slapped my shoulder that's not
it doesn't count
and it was just fifteen minutes of that
and somehow he won I was I don't know I
don't even know why I brought that up
this is a feat thing because if it he
couldn't definitely got his toe in the
dudes mouth yeah he could have pulled it
off they like slow-mo one of the kicks
like you don't see what happens it's
like a full 360 and that dudes just just
falls down and like I don't even think
he made contact let's let's go to the
replay let's see what actually happens
oh it's just his toe yeah it's like so
fast but it's totus comes on let's get
up let's get a closer look at that let's
get a closer look at that
he's like so next the big toe like gets
in I just like flicks the tongue like
it's like a little from the bottom it's
like oh he got him on the taste bud you
got him on the taste bud Wow amazing
what a move there so tell us what was
the game plan going into this fight well
you know my feet are so nice and and
that's a real intimidating thing for
most men in the sport so I figure if I
just dip my toe in this fulls mouth I'll
be able to take the W he's a smart
fighter Joe it really is anyway toes in
the mouth how's it going yeah we beat
that one again
on a flex then I'm holding half his bags
I'm trying to flex not trying to flex
take your fish to nourish and break
that's not a flex